[Musik]
guten morgen aus china guten ausgang
sagte wir sind hier im ski und snowboard
park und steffi loos vorher im bus
hierher deine mutter verloren jetzt
wichtigste frage kannst du ohne mütze
auch zu den coolen kids hier dazu
gehören wie machst du das
ich habe zum glück noch so eine
skibrille dabei also ich kann mich noch
geschönt haben aber ja also ich habe
hier schon jetzt ein bisschen probleme
alle haben wir mal so hippe sachen an
und weite klamotten roxy und outfits
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so erlebte tage du warst ja öfters hier
du bist unsere global expert den hier in
china immer ein bisschen ja heute war
das halbfinale das team
hat gewonnen schon am ersten platz sie
war ziemlich stark obwohl sie erzählt
hatte in der pressekonferenz ist die ihr
heute morgen um diese mentale probleme
hatte und auch im training ihre runs
nicht so richtig landen konnte aber beim
ersten hat es dann geklappt und es ist
auch mal so eine besondere stimmung hat
man das gefühl irgendwie so ganz einfach
spürt unter den athletinnen und athleten
als vielleicht beim ski wurde nach nach
regen den berichten auf bin kann es dann
ein bisschen drüber erzählen ja total
also gestern war zum beispiel die
qualifikation der männer und es ist ganz
interessant weil es haben russland
australier schweizerdeutsche haben alle
an gefeiert und es war jetzt aber nicht
so dass nur die deutschen sozusagen den
deutschen am begrifflich an gefeiert
haben sondern wie auch beim slowenen zum
beispiel ziemlich laut irgendwie
irritiert haben alle zusammen also man
merkt das spielt nicht so die rolle die
rheiner kenntnis aller genannten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich habe es jetzt ja nicht live
gesehen aber
emotionale szene mit micaela schäfer
ausgestiegen ist das ist mein ziel
genauso wie ihr zweites olympia rennen
die große favoritin wo man bei jedem
rennen erwartet dass sie auch gewinnt
also wenn sie antritt dann muss sie auch
gewinnen so die erwartungshaltung in
amerika wo sie herkommt und dass sie im
riesenslalom ersten rennen ausgeschieden
und gestern am mittwoch am fünften tor
im ersten lauf des slaloms los wieder
raus und dann sah sie erst mal alleine
im schnee und später als sie dann in der
mixedzone war also eine riesige traube
an journalisten vor allem aus amerika
wirklich 30 handys vor ihr haben sie
stand da hat erstmalig kaum ein wort
rausgebracht erst mal in 15 sekunden
pause und also worte gesucht die sie
nicht gefunden hat und das war schon ja
also nicht in ein großes drama und gab
aus deutscher sicht auch noch ein
kleines drama und ich später lena dürr
die nach dem ersten durchgang erster war
und dann am ende als sie nach dem
zweiten durchgang zwar 19
hundertstelsekunden rückstand und damit
von 14 zurückgefallen ist also nicht mal
auf zwei nicht mal nach drei auf vier
und dann dieser ja undankbare vierte
platz bei olympia den dem man ja nicht
haben will und kannst du mir erzählen
die liebsten da war brauchte ich meine
wir haben ja irgendwie alles im flugzeug
diesen tag gesehen das sind ja
eigentlich nur so graue berge auf den so
ein paar weiße schnee spuren also wie
ist es denn überhaupt dazu seien
genommen also manschetten mit der gondel
irgendwann diesen diesem berg hoch der
berg auf den es eigentlich so gut wie
nie schneit dann sieht man zum ersten
mal in dieser region wo wir eigentlich
ski wettbewerbe stattfinden dann zum
ersten mal schnee und die wie sowieso
weiße streifen in so einem braunen
braune ware also ist das wirklich schon
ab so dass bild und wenn ich kann man
kein bisschen lernen auch mal für die
texte die beschreiben die
sonntagszeitung schreibe ich über dieses
thema
großen text also frankfurter allgemeine
sonntagszeitung schott reinlässt mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so steffi ist ein thema das sind sie
auch irgendwie so als olympe
reporterinnen und reporter beschäftigt
so bewegungsfreiheit oder die ja keine
bewegungsfreiheit was uns so irgendwie
deine erfahrungen aus jetzt der knapp
der ersten woche peking wie es mit der
bewegung ja also ich meine ich glaub ich
weiß aber
auch noch muss im slopestyle parcours
und zu der
deswegen dass er nicht ganz gut aber
wenn man jetzt irgendwo hin laufen weil
das generell schwierig weil man muss
eigentlich im bus reden und selbst wenn
es nur ein paar meter sind muss man den
nächsten bus neben als man darf nicht
auf weil man sonst gefahr läuft aus der
verbrauch habe ich eine gute geschichte
noch vor den abend also ich möchte eben
dem bus angekommen bin bei uns im hotel
der held zu einer station also an seiner
station und man kann unser zimmer unser
gebäude sehen das wirklich 50 schritte
vielleicht 100 höchstens aber man darf
diese 100 schritte nicht laufen weil
dafür noch mal extra bus vorgesehen dass
er dann aus nur um das hotel fährt
handy ist in die security zone rein und
gestern einfach so kalt und der bus kam
nicht und dann bin ich und mit zwei
kollegen wir sind einfach gelaufen das
jetzt wir trauen uns jetzt sehr hoch zu
laufen und da standen wir vor der
schranke wo der polizist uns erstmal in
seine diktieren gesprochen hat die dann
übersetzt hat okay was macht ihr hier
dürfte hier her laufen und dann haben
wir bestimmt noch 10 50 minuten
gebraucht mit unserem hotelzimmer karten
mit unserer akkreditierung um ihnen dann
klar zu machen okay wir wohnen hier und
dann hat er nachdem er noch von uns
allen drei fotos gemacht hat und auch
dann glücklicherweise reingelassen
problem auch natürlich mit dem mit der
bewegungsfreiheit du kannst dich einfach
die mütze kaufen gehen ja das ist
wirklich ein problem was ich jetzt
gerade hier könnte ich ein
shoppingcenter jene der mütze kaufen
aber ich habe ja mit gedacht und auch
deutschland eine zweite mit dabei
also mütze von mir die kann man gar
nicht früh genug sein für snowboard aber
zumindest die ohren
[Musik]